there's enough room for everybody you
know there's there's only probably one
room for a national play of the year and
you know it is through the the eyes of
the beholder you know that's that I mean
Caitlin Clark does she deserve it
absolutely
does Aaliyah Boston deserve it
absolutely does Cameron break deserve it
absolutely like there are so many people
are deserving of it so let's tell all
the story let's not just be one-sided
[Music]
all right coach congratulations are in
order you have 400 wins as South
Carolina's head coach you're going back
to the sweet 16. so I know you are very
busy at the moment so let's get uh right
into it
um I talk about this quote a lot on the
show it's a quote from Nick Saban and he
says once you get to the top of the
mountain you become the mountain do you
feel like South Carolina is now that
mountain
I don't I don't and I don't know if it's
because
um
um I've been I've been at the foot of
the mountain a lot
um trying to get to the top of the
mountain and now you know that we've had
sustained success you're you're I'm
always in the mode of trying to get
better trying to trying to do the
unthinkable trying to to be that
mountain and um we find ourselves here
and it just feels like you you're still
working like you're still working trying
to build on top of what we've already
built
how close do you feel
um I mean there there are good days and
there are bad days as far as how close I
think I'm too close to our team really I
am I see it every day I know what our
deficiencies are I know the areas where
we need to improve so it's like but I
know we're we're actually excellent I
know we're excellent and I could I could
see that and
um but the The Balancing Act of of
knowing where you're excellent and
knowing where your deficiencies are
keeps me in a good place where I don't
allow myself to get too big-headed
because because of those deficiencies so
um we're we're I've always said it you
know throughout this entire season we're
just still a work in progress we're
actually getting better than every
single day and I I feel that
so for you what's heavier
the pressure of winning that first
championship or the pressure to keep
winning championships
um probably the pressure to win the
first one
um because it's it's it for me it was a
lifelong dream it was something that
growing up in the projects in North
Philly is one of two events that I saw
women play that was a national
championship and then I saw women play
in the Olympics and those were my two
goals that I wanted to accomplish
um when I was just growing up in the
sport and I was able to get the gold
medal and then I didn't think I would
ever be in the position to win a
National Championship because I didn't
want to coach so I was happy with the
gold medal and then coaching found me
and then that that desire to want to win
the national championship just it got it
grew bigger and bigger you know inside
of me to where you know I I wanted it
more than anything and then I obviously
change coaching
um programs from Temple to South
Carolina because I thought South
Carolina would put us in a better
position to win a National Championship
and then you know it took took 17 years
as a coach to actually hoist that trophy
I love that
um I am keeping this question
intentionally very broad what do you
want for Aaliyah Boston well that's
that's a group that's a great question
um I I want
I want Aaliyah Boston's
heart desires like I want whatever her
heart desires because of what she's been
not to just our program because you know
that is written that's written already
um what's not written is what she means
to this game I I know that you know once
she leaves College women's basketball
I know for certain that we will never
get a person that embodies what a
student athlete what a giver what
um someone's so strong in faith she
realizes that where all these things
that are happening for her that she's
truly favored by God so not only what
what Aaliyah wants and what her heart
desires but what God wants for her
and I want her I want him to put her at
ease because she she
high standard she said a high sander for
herself so and she puts the work into it
she's not one of those you know people
or or athletes that say I want to be a
national Player of the Year defensive
National player of the year without the
work and that is really really different
from most young people nowadays like
they wanted instant gratification no
Aaliyah wants to work for it she wants
to see the fruit of her labor and she
wants to see it in in the form of
probably you know more Hardware more
national championships more National
play of the years more National
defensive play of the year more Lisa
Leslie Awards so she wants to see that
and I I do want to see that for her and
I want her to have an incredible WNBA
career
I love that and I think that Aaliyah
Boston is so special both on and off the
court and you have continued to make
comments about her that are very
important one that I want to repeat
um and ask if you could explain what you
meant by this you said what's good for
the game is to call it like you see it
don't create narratives don't create
things that are advantageous to players
that will get the most clicks what did
you mean by that statement
um what I meant by that is our our game
women's basketball we have a tendency to
create a narrative and we stick with
that narrative no matter no matter who
it is I mean it was it was given to a
lot of different players throughout
throughout their careers but there's so
much more like there's there's so much
more to our game you know there is
Caitlin Clark there is Aaliyah Boston
there is Cameron Brink you know there is
I mean Ole Miss just be a number one
seed last night there are so so many
stories that are buried because we we go
with this narrative and
we we not only we don't only keep it
contained in in our game we go to the
the men's game like I hear I hear
um commentators talk about Caitlyn Clark
on different like I watched men's
basketball they're talking about her
name do they know her maybe maybe not is
somebody telling them to to speak on it
maybe maybe not but I but I know I know
from I know from speaking to a lot of
people that when these narratives are
created
come hella high water they're sticking
with them I mean we were a victim of in
2020 being the number one team in the
country uh for the last nine weeks
before covet hit and you wouldn't know
you would not know that we were the
number one team because they they kept
with the narrative with um Sabrina and
ask you which is fine great great player
there'll never be another Sabrina
but because because of Sabrina and I
don't mean that like dog pound or her
name you'll never know about the 2020.
our the number one team in the country
when covet hit you'll you'll never know
about it unless we're bringing it up and
that's a shame because there was room
for Sabrina there was room for uh Ty
Harris and Kiki Herbert Harrigan the
leaders of our team that got a 2019
number one recruiting class in a
position of
I think we would have won a national
championship we were playing so much you
know elevated you know and we just got
better and better and better and maybe
that story would have been told if we
had a sorry a an NCAA tournament
but when I talked to the decision makers
I asked them and they said we were going
to tell that story in the tournament
when the bottle fell out so you don't
get a chance to tell the story now I
will say because of that those
conversations we did get a a an hour
piece called for the culture that was
exquisitely done like it was awesome
but selfish you know selfishly it was
great but there were other stories that
did not get told
um that that's a Lost season for
everyone and I just think that
um there's enough room for everybody you
know there's there's only probably one
room for a national play of the year and
you know it is through the the eyes of
the beholder you know that's not I mean
Caitlin Clark does she deserve it
absolutely
does Aaliyah Boston deserve it
absolutely does Cameron break deserve it
absolutely like there are so many people
are deserving of it so let's tell all
the story let's not just be one-sided
well I think what you're saying is true
but I think it begs the question of why
do you feel like certain players or
people are left out of narratives and
why are certain players and people
brought into narratives
I mean it's obviously there
you know people who feel like
I mean I don't want to get into the the
race thing because I'm not race baiting
or any anything like that when you when
Aaliyah looks different she looks
different she's I mean she's a she's a
big young woman like she's a center and
usually centers aren't the players that
are highlighted in that way but
I mean she's bubbly if you pour it into
like clay Caitlin Clark we all know is
the is is the one that that people feel
like is the national play of the year
and this uh narratives that have been
created for her and she deserves it
honestly she deserves it I don't want
people thinking I'm you know just trying
to elevate my player I'm not I know what
great players look like I do she is that
like Sabrina and ask you what's that
okay Asia Wilson definitely was that
Randy Stewart what's that Diana Taurasi
was that like there there are so many
but we don't know who those other
players are we don't we don't know
because we are we are pushing one like
we're pushing one and then we're we're
pushing Caitlyn but I I do think we do
as as South Carolina we do get some Pub
as a as an entire team so I don't want
to I don't want I I like having these
conversations because
um they need to be had and they they
really need to be had because it's not
hate like it's like people think I hate
on Caitlyn I don't like Caitlyn is going
to probably win the dawn Staley award
for the third year in a row not not
because I'm favoring her it's because
she can flat out play quite simple like
quite simple
yeah I had a conversation uh with Sue
bird about this topic once and she put
it really eloquently just saying you
know they trick women's athletes into
thinking that everybody is fighting for
the pond like there's a pond there's a
pool she's like but really there's a
whole ocean but when they make you think
you only have this like tiny body of
water you're thinking that you're having
to like put one player above the other
when really there should be room for all
people to be highlighted and to have
these narratives and to have these
stories so I think what you're saying is
is really important there has to be ways
that we're able to incorporate
everyone's stories in ways that feel
real and authentic to them so I
appreciate you giving your your
perspective on that
um and one thing we just add this yeah
let me just let me just add this and Sue
is you know completely right about that
um I I do feel like I do feel like the
narratives are are created as such that
we go to the other end of the spectrum
like we start hating on
um that that one that that chosen one
and we shouldn't do that we shouldn't do
that I know our our fan base is love to
go Tit for Tat but it's not there is
room like we need to respect we need to
respect the whole spectrum of of all the
the people that make our game great like
there are so many people that make our
game great we have so much dissension in
our game that we can't we can't Elevate
we can't Elevate we need to we need to
join our voices together to make sure
that we're all getting are just due in
this space because the more we all get
our Jets do the more the more the
decision makers are going to have to
publicize what needs to be publicized
and that's that's our Rich Game
yeah absolutely no I love that
um shifting gear is a little bit uh when
you think of your entire basketball
career I mean as a player as a coach
everything
what is the one loss that you remember
the most and what's the one win that you
remember the most
the one loss
um
I'm gonna say this is
the most recent one because people have
been asking
um asking our
our senior class this question like we
only lost one game in their entire
four-year career at home
at home
and it was uh it was against NC State
and it was on national television and I
had never like we played
uncharacteristically bad like I did not
know that team like I didn't know it
like it was it was all it got brand new
you know how people said don't get brand
new on me they got brand new and I was
in this is it stuck with me and now that
people are asking that that feeling
still gets even though they won the rest
of the games like I think we were 60 and
one I don't I think 60 and one in our
building so that's the one loss that is
the most current one
um and then the the win
um I I would say
I would say probably
beating UConn for the first time here in
our building in 2020.
because so many so many other Monumental
wins came after that so it kind of
opened the door for us being able to you
know just shake that off of them I
always say I always describe it as this
Yukon beating our heads in year after
year after year after year so so that
went here allowed us allowed us to win
here and also to win last year in the
national championship game
yeah you know the South Carolina Yukon
matchups are always super fascinating
how would you describe the relationship
between both those schools and the
relationship between you and Geno
um let me I wouldn't even say we're
Rivals because you gotta win you got you
got the the percentage of them beating
us is very high to our you know low
um I I just think it's a it's a it's
become a great
um anticipation game for for all of
basketball not just College not just
women's basketball but all of college
basketball because when when it's put on
television the the viewership is is way
way up and then as far as my
relationship with with Gino you know I
respect Gino I do I respect Gino I I
coached under him in the 2016 Olympic
Games I've watched I watched them I
watched him a lot he probably didn't
know I was watching him but I was
watching and learning just to see how he
operates
um
um and then I I just I just respect them
there's a there's a I think a mutual
respect for each other
um we we don't like losing and we don't
like losing each other
I love that okay well final question for
you I know we have to wrap up but my
last question is a what if what if you
weren't a basketball coach what would
you be doing
wow you gonna take me there
um I'm really highly competitive
and I probably think
I can have my way in the casino so I'll
probably be a professional gambler
wow I love that answer what blackjack
Blackjack roulette you name it I don't
know craps though
I know somebody has to teach me now I
know the hood craps I just don't say I
know that one I don't know
I know I don't know the crab tape
I love that answer oh my goodness well I
know you are oppressed for time I deeply
appreciate you doing this I don't know
if you remember this but I interviewed
you about a year ago and one thing that
you were talking about is that you said
you had a debt to repay the basketball
and you just wanted basketball to be
proud of you I hope that you feel that
you are so close to repaying that debt
and I hope that you know that everybody
within the basketball Community does
root for you so I deeply appreciate you
doing this and good luck in the rest of
the tournament thank you so much I
appreciate it
please